The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We looked at
the macro state, where
the volume of the box, the
temperature were given,
as well as the
chemical potential.
So rather than looking at a
fixed number of particles,
we were looking at the
grand canonical prescription
where the chemical
potential was specified.
We said that when
we have a system
of non-interacting
particles, we can construct
a many bodied state based on
occupation of single particle
states such that the action
of the Hamiltonian on this
will give me a sum over
all single particle
states, the occupation number
of that single particle
state times the energy of that
single particle state, and then
the state back.
We said that in
quantum mechanics,
we have to distinguish
between bosons and fermions,
and in the occupation
number prescription.
For the case of fermions,
corresponding theta v minus 1
and k was 01.
For the case of bosons,
corresponding theta
plus 1 and k equals [INAUDIBLE].
We said that within this
planned canonical prescription,
these occupation numbers
were independently given.
The probabilities
were independently
distributed according
to exponential rules
such that when we
calculated the average, nk.
We commented on
the statistics what
are the very simple forms,
which was 1 over [INAUDIBLE]
into the beta
epsilon k minus eta,
where z was constructed
from the temperature
and the temporal potential as
[INAUDIBLE] to the beta mu.
Now, for the case that
we are interested,
for this gas that is
in a box of volume v,
the one particle states
were characterized
by [INAUDIBLE] waves
and their energies
were f h bar squared k squared
over 2m, basically just
the kinetic energy.
And then at various
stages, we have
to perform sums over k's,
and for a box of volume v,
the sum over k was
replaced in the limit
of a large box with an
integral over k times
the density of states, which
was v divided by 2 pi cubed.
And we said that
again, we recognized
that quantum particles have
another characteristic, which
is their spin, and there is a
degeneracy factor associated
with that that we can
just stick over here
as if we had [INAUDIBLE]
copies corresponding
to the different
components of the spin.
Now, once we put this form
of epsilon k over here,
then we can calculate what
the mean number of particles
is in the grand
canonical ensemble as sum
over k, the average nk, given
the appropriate statistics.
Of course, this is a
quantity that is extensive.
We then construct a
density, which is intensive,
simply by dividing by v, which
gets rid of that factor of v
over here, and we found
that the answer could
be written as g over
lambda cubed, again,
coming from this g, lambda cubed
from the change of variables,
where we defined lambda
and h over root 2 pi mkp.
And then a function that
we indicated by s 3/2,
depending on the
statistics of z.
And this was a member of
our class of functions
we defined in
general, f m h of z,
to be 1 over m minus 1
factorial, integral 0
to infinity, ex, x to
the m minus 1, z inverse,
e to the x minus eta.
So for each m, we
have a function of z.
In fact, we have two
functions, depending
on whether we are dealing
with the fermionic
or the bosonic variety.
We saw that these
functions we could expand
for small z as z plus eta
z squared over 2 to the m.
It's an alternating
series for fermions.
All terms are positive for
bosons, zq, 3 to the m,
eta z to the fourth, 4
to the m, and so forth.
And we also noted
that these functions
have a nice property
in that if you
were to take a derivative with
respect to z and multiply by z,
you get the function
with one lower index.
So this is, in
fact, the same thing
as z divided by zz of
f m plus 1 [INAUDIBLE].
This just made the connection
between the number of particles
and the chemical
potential that we
need to use when we go to the
grand canonical prescription,
but we are interested in
calculating various properties
of this gas, such
as the pressure.
We found that the
formula for the pressure
was simply g over lambda
cubed, very similar to what
we had over here, except that,
rather than having f 3/2,
we had f 5/2 of z to
deal with, and if we
were interested in energy,
we could simply use 3/2.
Indeed, this was correct for
both fermions and bosons,
irrespective of the
difficulties or the variations
in pressure that you
would have, depending
on your bosons or fermions
due to [INAUDIBLE] gases.
So what is the task
here, if you are
interested in getting
a formula for pressure
or the energy or
the heat capacity?
What should we do if we are
interested in a gas that
has a fixed number of
particles or a fixed density?
Clearly, the first
stage is to calculate
z as a function of density.
What we can do is to solve the
first equation graphically.
We have to solve the
equation f 3/2 8 of z
equals the combination
m lambda cubed over g,
which we call the
degeneracy factor.
So if I tell you what
the temperature is,
you know lambda.
If I tell you what
the density is,
you know the combination
on the right hand side.
There is this function.
We have to plot this
function and find
the value of the
argument of the function.
That gives the value of
m lambda cubed over g
as the value of the function.
So graphically,
what we have to do
is to plot as a function of
z these functions, f 3/2.
I will generically
plot f m 8 of z,
but for the case that
we are interested,
we really need to
look at m equals 3/2.
As we will see in
problem set, if you
were to solve the
gas in d dimensions,
this m rather than the
3/2 would be g over 2.
So pictorially, the
same thing would
work with slightly
different forms
of these functions in
different dimensions.
How do these
functions look like?
Well, we see that initially,
they start to be linear,
but then, the case of the bosons
and fermions, the next order
term goes in
different directions.
And in particular, for
the case of fermions,
the quadratic term
starts to bring you down,
whereas for the case of
bosons, the quadratic term
is the opposite direction and
will tend to make you large.
This is what these
functions look.
For the case of fermions, I have
additional terms in the series.
It's an alternating series.
And then the question
is, what happens
to this at large values of z?
And what we found was
that at large values,
this function satisfies
the asymptotic form
that is provided by
Sommerfeld formula, which
states that f m of z, for the
case of fermions, so this is
eta equals minus 1,
is log z to the power
of m divided by m factorial.
Of course, we are
interested in m goes to 3/2.
1 plus pi squared
over 6 m, m minus 1,
log z squared, and higher order
inverse powers of log z, which
one can compute, but
for our purposes,
these two terms are sufficient.
And if I'm interested in doing
the inversion for fermions,
what I need to do is to
plot a line that corresponds
to n lambda cubed
over g and find
the intersection of
that line, and that
would give me the value of z.
When I'm very close
to the origin,
I start with the
linear behavior,
and then I can systematically
calculate the corrections
to the linear behavior, which
would have been z equals n
lambda cubed over g in higher
powers of n lambda cubed
over g.
And we saw that by doing
that, I can gradually
construct a visual
expansion that
is appropriate for these gases.
I can do the same thing, of
course, for the case of bosons
also, but now I'm interested
in the limiting form where
the density goes higher and
higher or the temperature
goes lower and lower so that
this horizontal line that I
have drawn will go to
larger and larger values,
and I'm interested in the
intersections that I have
when z is large and this
asymptotic formula is
being satisfied.
So what do I need to do for the
case of degenerate fermions?
I have this quantity, n lambda
cubed over g, which I claim
is much larger than
1, so I have to look
for values of the function, f
3/2 minus of z that are large,
and those values are achieved
when the argument is large,
and then it takes the form
log z to the 3/2 divided
by 3/2 factorial, 1
plus pi squared over 6.
m in this case is 3/2,
so I have 3/2 times m
minus 1, which is 1/2,
divided by log z over 2.
And then I will have
potentially higher order terms.
So I can invert this
formula to find log
z as a function of density.
And to lowest order,
what I have is
3/2 factorial n lambda cubed
over g raised to the 2/3 power.
If I were to ignore
everything here,
just arrange things
this way, that's
the formula that I would get.
But then I have this
correction, so I divide by this.
I have 1 plus-- this combination
is equivalent to pi squared
over 8, 1 over log z squared.
I have taken it to the other
side, so I put the minus sign
and raise again
to the 2/3 power.
Now, the way that I have defined
z up there, clearly log z
is proportional to beta nu.
We can see that
lambda is proportional
to beta to the 1/2,
so lambda cubed
is beta to the 3/2, which,
when raised to the 2/3,
gives me a factor of beta.
So basically, the quantity
that we have over here
is of the order of
beta, and then we
saw that the remainder,
which depends on properties
such as the mass
of the gas, gh, et
cetera, which is independent
of temperature, is a constant.
That is the Fermi
energy that we can
compute by usual route
of filling up a Fermi c.
And the value of
epsilon f is h bar
squared over 2m
times kf squared,
and the kf was 6 pi squared
n over g to the 1/3 power,
so kf squared would be
something like this.
So once we know the density
of the fermion, its spin
and its mass, we can figure
out what this quantity is.
The zeroth order solution
for the chemical potential
is clearly this epsilon f.
What do I have to do
if I want to calculate
the next correction?
Well, what I can do is I
can put the zeroth order
solution for log z
in this expression,
and then that will give me
the first order correction.
I have to raise this whole
thing to the minus 2/3 power,
so pi squared over 8
becomes 1 minus 2/3
of pi squared over h, which
is minus pi squared over 12.
1 over log of z squared--
log z is again mu over kt,
so its inverse is kt
over the zeroth order
value of mu, which is epsilon
f raised to second power,
and we expect that there
will be higher order terms.
So what have I stated?
If I really take
this curve and try
to solve for mu as a function
of temperature for a given
density, I find that at
very low temperatures,
the value that I
get is epsilon f,
and then the value
starts to get reduced
as I go to higher temperatures
and the initial fall
is quadratic.
Of course, the function will
have higher and higher order
corrections.
It will not stay quadratic.
And I also know that
at very large values,
it essentially converges
to a form that is minus
kt log of n lambda cubed,
because down here, I
know that this solution is z is
simply n lambda cubed over g.
So at low densities and high
temperatures, basically,
I will have something
that is almost
linear with logarithmic
corrections and negative,
and so presumably, the function
looks something like this.
Of course, I can always convert.
We can say that
what I see here is
the combination of
kt over epsilon f.
I can define epsilon f
over kv to be something
that I'll call tf,
and this correction
I can write as t
over tf squared.
So basically, I have
defined epsilon f
to be some kv times
a Fermi temperature.
Just on the basis of
dimensional argument,
you would expect that the place
where this zero is occurring
is of the order of this tf.
I don't claim that
it is exactly tf.
It will have some
multiplicative factor,
but it will be of
the order of tf,
which can be related
to the density, mass,
and other properties of
the gas by this formula.
And if you look at a
metal, such as copper,
where the electrons are
approximately described
by this Fermi gas, this tf
is of the order of, say,
10 to the 4 degrees Kelvin.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you were saying
that at a high temperature,
the chemical potential
should go as minus kvt
times ln of n
lambda cubed, yeah?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Now, the lambda itself
has temperature dependence,
so how can you claim that
it is behaving linearly?
PROFESSOR: I said
almost linearly.
As you say, the correct behavior
is something like minus 3/2 t
log t, so log t
changes the exponent
to be slightly different from 1.
This is not entirely linear.
It has some curvature
due to this logarithm.
In fact, something that people
sometimes get confused at
is when you go to high
temperatures, beta goes to 0.
So why doesn't z go to 1?
Of course, beta goes
to 0 but mu goes
to infinity such that the
product of 0 and infinity
is actually still pretty
large, partly because
of this logarithm.
AUDIENCE: Could you just
explain again why it's linear?
PROFESSOR: Down
here it is linear,
so I know that z is n
lambda cubed over g.
z is e to the mu over kt.
So mu is kt log of n
lambda cubed over g.
Remember lambda
depends on temperature,
so it is almost linear, except
that really what is inside here
has a temperature dependence.
So it's really
more like t log t.
AUDIENCE: When z is small?
PROFESSOR: When z is small
and only when z is small,
and z small corresponds
to being down here.
Again, that's what I was saying.
Down here, beta
goes to zero but mu
goes to minus infinity such
that the product of 0 and minus
infinity is still something that
is large and negative because
of this.
AUDIENCE: If the product is
large, then isn't z large?
PROFESSOR: If the product
is large and negative,
then z is exponentially small.
In fact, if I were to
plot this function just
without the higher
order corrections,
if I plot the function, kt
log of n lambda cubed over g,
you can see that it goes
to 0 when the combination n
lambda cubed over g is
1 because log of 1 is 0.
So that function by
itself, asymptotically this
is what I have, it will come
and do something like this,
but it really is not something
that we are dealing with.
It's in some sense
the classical version.
So classically, your mu
is given by this formula,
except that
classically, you don't
know what the volume factor
is that you have to put there
because you don't
know what h is.
So that's the
chemical potential,
but the chemical
potential is really,
for our intents and
purposes, a device
that I need to put here
in order to calculate
the pressure, to calculate
the energy, et cetera.
So let's go to the next step.
We are again in this limit.
Beta p is g over lambda
cubed f 5/2 plus z.
That's going to give me g over
lambda cubed in the limit where
z is large-- we established that
z is large-- log z to the 5/2
divided by 5/2 factorial
using the Sommerfeld
expansion, 1 plus pi over 6.
Now my m is 5/2.
m minus 1 would be 3/2
divided by log z squared
in higher order terms.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is that plus?
PROFESSOR: Because
I made a mistake.
Just to make my life and
manipulations easier,
I'll do the following.
I write under this
the formula for n
being g over lambda cubed,
f 3/2 minus z, which
is g over lambda
cubed log z to the 3/2
divided by 3/2 factorial,
1 plus-- I calculated
the correction-- pi
squared over 6 divided
by various combination,
which is pi squared over 8,
1 over log z squared.
Now what I will do is to
divide these two equations.
If I were to divide the
numerator by the denominator,
what do I get?
The left hand side
becomes beta p over n.
The right hand side, I can
get rid of the ratio of log
z 5/2 to log z.
3/2 is just one factor of log z.
What do I have when I divide
5/2 factorial by 3/2 factorial?
I have 5/2.
This division allows me to get
rid of some unwanted terms.
And then what do I have here?
This combination here is 5
pi squared over 8 minus 1 pi
squared over 8.
Because of the division, I
will put a minus sign here,
so that becomes 4
pi squared over 8,
which is pi squared over 2.
So I will get 1 plus
pi squared over 2,
and at the order
that we are dealing,
we can replace 1
over log z squared
with kt over epsilon f squared.
Now, for log z over here,
I can write beta mu,
and for mu, I can write the
formula that I have up here.
So you can see that once I
do that, the betas cancel
from the two sides of the
equation, and what I get
is that p is 2/5,
the inverse of 5/2.
The n I will take to the
other side of the equation.
To the lowest
order mu is epsilon
f, so I will put epsilon f, but
mu is not exactly epsilon f.
It is 1 minus pi squared over
12, kt over epsilon f squared.
And actually, there was
this additional factor of 1
plus pi squared over 2,
kt over epsilon f squared.
So what do we find?
We find that to
the zeroth order,
pressure is related
to the density
but multiplied by epsilon f, so
that even at zero temperature,
there is a finite
value of pressure left.
So we are used to ideal
gases that are classical,
and when we go to
zero temperature,
they start to stop
moving around.
Since they are
not moving around,
there is no pressure that is
exerted, but for the Fermi gas,
you cannot say that all of the
particles are not moving around
because that violates this
exclusion of n being zero
or one.
You have to give particles
more and more momentum
so that they don't violate the
condition that they should have
different values of the
occupation numbers, the Pauli
exclusion.
And therefore, even
at zero temperature,
you will have particles
that in the ground state
are zipping around, and
because they're moving around,
they can hit the wall
and exert pressure on it,
and this is the value
of the pressure.
As you go to higher temperature,
that pressure gets modified.
We can see that balancing
these two terms,
there is an increase
in pressure, which
is 1 plus 5 pi squared over
6, kt over epsilon f squared.
So you expect the
pressure, if I plot it
as a function of temperature,
at zero temperature,
it will have this
constant value, pf.
As I put a higher
temperature, there
will be even more energy
and more kinetic energy,
and the pressure will rise.
Eventually, at very
high temperatures,
I will regain the
classical, rather
pressure is proportional
to temperature.
That's the pressure of
this ideal Fermi gas.
The energy.
Well, the energy
is simply what we
said over here, always 3/2 pv.
So it is 3/2, the pressure
over there multiplied
by v. When I multiply
the density by v,
I will get the
number of particles.
3/2 times 5/2 will give me
3/5, so I will 3/5 and epsilon
f at the lowest order.
Again, you've probably
seen this already
where you draw diagrams
for filling up a Fermi c.
Up to some particular
kf, you would
say that all states
are occupied.
When epsilon f is the
energy of this state that
is sitting right at the
edge of the Fermi c,
and clearly, the
energies of the particles
vary all the way from
zero up to epsilon f,
so the average energy is going
to be less than epsilon f.
Dimensionally, it works
out to be 3/5 of that.
That's what that says.
But the more
important part is how
it changes as a
function of temperature.
What you find is that it goes
to 1 plus 5 pi squared over 6,
kt over epsilon f squared
in high order terms.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Should the 6 be 12?
PROFESSOR: 6 should be 12?
Let's see.
This is 6/12 minus
1/12 is indeed 5/12.
Thank you.
So if I ask what's the heat
capacity at constant volume,
this is dE by dT, so just
taking the derivative.
The zeroth order term,
of course, is irrelevant.
It doesn't vary the temperature.
It's this t squared that
will give you the variations.
So what does it give me?
I will have n epsilon f.
I have 3/5 times 5
pi squared over 12.
The derivative of
this combination
will give me 2kb squared t
divided by epsilon f squared.
There will be, of
course, higher order,
but this combination you can
see I can write as follows.
It is extensive.
It is proportional to n.
There is one kb that I can
take out, which is nice,
because natural units
of heat capacity,
as we have emphasized, are kb.
This combination of numbers,
I believe the 5 cancels.
3 times 2 divided
by 12 gives me 1/2,
so I have pi squared over 2.
And then I have the
combination, kt over epsilon
f, which I can also
write as t over tf.
So the heat capacity
of the Fermi gas
goes to 0 as I go
to zero temperature,
in accord with the third
law of thermodynamics, which
we said is a consequence
of quantum mechanics.
So we have this result,
that the proportionality
is given by the inverse of tf.
If I were to plot the heat
capacity in units of nkb
as a function of t, at
very high temperatures,
I will get the classical
result, which is 3/2,
and then I will start to
get corrections to that.
Those corrections will
gradually reduce this,
so eventually, the function
that I will get starts linearly
and then gets matched to that.
So the linear behavior is
of the order of t over tf,
and presumably at
some temperature
that is of the order
of tf, you will
switch to some
classical behavior.
And as I said, if you look at
metals, this tf is very large.
So when you look at the
heat capacity of something
like copper or some
other metal, you
find that there is a
contribution from the electrons
to the heat capacity
that is linear.
Now, the reason for
this linear behavior
is also good to understand.
This calculation that
I did is necessary
in order to establish what this
precise factor of pi squared
over 2 or appropriate
coefficient
is, but the physical reason
for the linearity you
should be able to know.
Basically, we saw that
the occupation numbers
for the case of fermions
have this form that
is 1 over z inverse, e
to the epsilon plus 1.
If I plot the occupation
numbers as a function of energy,
for a case that is
at zero temperature,
you can see that the
occupation number is 1 or 0,
so you have a picture
that is like this.
You switch from 1
to 0 at epsilon f.
Oops, there was a beta here
that I forgot, beta epsilon.
When I go to finite
temperature, this becomes fuzzy
because this expectation
value for the number,
rather than being a
one zero step function,
becomes smoothed out,
becomes a function
such as this, and the width
over which this smoothing takes
place is of the order of kt.
So what happens is that rather
than having this short Fermi c,
you will start having
less particles here
and more occupied
particles over here.
To do that, you have
created energies
going from here to here
that you have stored
that is of the order of this kt.
What fraction of
the total number
have you given this energy?
Well, the fraction
is given from here.
It is the ratio of
this to the entirety,
and that ratio is
t, or kt, divided
by epsilon f is
the fraction that
has been given energy this.
So the excitation
energy that you have
is this number, the
total times this fraction
times the energy that
you have, which is kt.
And if I take the
derivative of this,
I will get precisely
this formula over
here up to this factor
of pi squared over 2,
which I was very cavalier,
but the scaling everything
comes from this.
And to all intents
and purposes, this
is the characteristic
of all Fermi systems,
that as you go to
low temperatures,
there is a small fraction
of electrons, if you like,
that can be excited.
That fraction goes to
0 at low temperatures
as kt over epsilon f, and the
typical energies that they have
is of the order of kt.
So essentially, many of the
results for the degenerate
Fermi gas you can obtain
by taking classical results
and substituting for
the number of particles
nkt over epsilon f.
You will see in the problem
set that this kind of argument
tells you something also
about the magnetic response
of a system of electrons,
what is the susceptibility
and why does the susceptibility
saturate at low temperatures.
It's just substituting for
the number of particles
this fraction, nkt
over epsilon f,
will give you lots of things.
This picture is also
valid in all dimensions,
whereas next, we'll be
discussing the case of bosons,
where the dependence
is on temperature.
There is an exponent
here that determines
which dimension you are
or depends on dimensions.
For the case of fermions, this
linearity exists independently.
So now let's think
about bosons and what's
going to happen for bosons.
For bosons, we saw that
the series, rather than
being alternating,
all of the terms
are adding up together so
that the parabolic correction,
rather than reducing
the function
for the case of bosons,
will increase it.
So for a particular
value of density,
we find that the z of fermions
is larger than the z of bosons.
So for a given
density, what we will
find is that the chemical
potential, whereas for the case
of fermions was deviating from
the classical form by going up,
for the case of
bosons, we'll start
to deviate from the
classical form and go down.
Now, there is
something, however,
that the chemical potential
cannot do for the case
of bosons which it did it
for the case of fermions,
and that was to change sign.
Why is that?
Well, we have that over
there, the occupation number
for a boson is 1
over z inverse, which
is e to the beta
epsilon k minus mu.
z inverse is e to the
minus meta mu minus 1.
Now, this result was
obtained from summing
a geometric series, and
the condition certainly
is that this object, that
is, the inverse of what
was multiplying different
terms in the series,
has to be larger than 1.
Of course, it has
to be larger than 1
so that I get a positive
occupation number.
If it was less than 1,
the geometric series
was never convergent.
Clearly, the negativity
of the occupation number
has no meaning.
So this being positive
strictly immediately implies
that mu has to be less
than epsilon k for all k.
So it has to be certainly less
than the minimum of epsilon k
with respect to all k.
And for the case that I'm
looking at where my epsilon
k's are h bar squared
k squared over 2m,
the lowest one
corresponds to k equals 0,
so mu has to be less than 0.
It can never go to the
other side of this.
Or alternatively, z
has to be less than
or approaches maybe 1.
So there is certainly
a barrier here
that we are going to encounter
for the case of bosons at z
equals 1.
We should not go
beyond that point.
So let's see what's
happening for z equals 1
to this function.
You see, my task
remains the same.
In order to find z, I
have to solve graphically
for the intersection of
the curve that corresponds
to f plus 3/2 and the curve that
corresponds to the density n
lambda cubed over g.
So what happens as I go to
higher and higher values
of n lambda cubed over g?
You can see one possibility
is that this curve just
diverges as z approaches 1.
Then for every value of
n lambda cubed over g,
you will find some value
of z that will gradually
become closer and closer to 1.
But is that the scenario?
For that, we need to know what
the value of this f function
is at z equals 1, so the limit
f m plus of z as z goes to 1.
How do you obtain that?
Well, that is 1 over m minus
1 factorial, integral 0
to infinity, dx, x to the m
minus 1, z inverse, which is 1,
e to the x minus 1.
I have to integrate
this function.
The integrand, how
does it look like?
x to the m minus 1,
e to the x minus 1.
Well, at large x,
there is no problem.
It goes to 0 exponentially.
At small x, it goes to
0 as x to the m minus 2.
So basically, it's
a curve such as this
that I have to integrate.
And if the curve is like I have
drawn it, there is no problem.
I can find the
integral underneath it
and there actually is a
finite value that has a name.
It's called a zeta function, so
this is some tabulated function
that you can look at.
But you can see that
if m, let's say, is 0,
then it is dx over x squared.
So the other
possibility is that this
is a function that diverges
at the origin, which
then may or may
not be integrable.
And we can see that this
is finite and exists only
for m that is larger then 1.
So in particular, we are
interested in the case
of m equals 3/2.
So then at z equals 1,
I have a finite value.
It is zeta of 3/2.
So basically, the function will
come up to a finite value at z
equals 1, which is
this zeta of 3/2,
which you can look up in tables.
It's 2.612.
Now, I tried to draw this
curve as if it comes and hugs
the vertical line tangentially,
that is, with infinite slope,
and that is the case.
Why do I know that?
Because the derivative
of the function
will be related to the
function at one lower index.
So the derivative of f
3/2 is really an f 1/2.
f 1/2 does not exist.
It's a function that
goes to infinity.
So essentially, this curve
comes with an infinite slope.
Now, it will turn out
that this is the scenario
that we have in
three dimensions.
If you are in two dimensions,
then what you need to do
is look at f that corresponds
to m equals 2 over 2 or 1,
and in that case, the
function diverges.
So then, you have no problem in
finding some intersection point
for any combination of
n lambda cubed over g.
But currently in
three dimensions,
we have a problem because
for n lambda cubed
over g that falls
higher than zeta of 3/2,
it doesn't hit the
curve at any point,
and we have to interpret
what that means.
So for d equals 3,
encounter singularity
when n lambda cubed
over g is greater than
or equal to zeta of 3/2.
This corresponds at a fixed
density to temperatures
that are less than some critical
temperature that depends on n,
and that I can read
off as being 1 over kb.
This is going to give
me a combination.
Lambda cubed is proportional
inversely to 3/2,
so this will give me nz
3/2 over g to the 2/3,
and then I have
h squared 2 pi m.
I put the kb over here.
So the more dense
your system is,
the lower-- I guess that's why
I have it the opposite way.
It should be the more dense it
is, the higher the temperature.
That's fine.
But what does that mean?
The point is that if we go
and look at the structure
that we have developed,
for any temperature that
is high enough, or any density
that is low enough, so that I
hit the curve on
its continuous part,
it means that I can find the
value of z that is strictly
less than 1, and
for that value of z,
I can occupy states according
to that probability,
and when I calculate
the net mean occupation,
I will get the actual density
that I'm interested in.
As I go to temperatures
that are lower,
this combination goes up and up.
The value of z that I have to
get gets pushed more towards 1.
As it gets pushed more towards
1, I see that mu going to 0,
the state that corresponds to
the lowest energy, k equals 0,
gets more and more occupied.
But still, nothing special about
that occupation except what
happens when I am
at higher values.
The most natural thing is that
when I am at higher values,
I should pick z equals
1 minus a little bit.
And if I choose z to be 1 minus
a very small quantity, then
when I do the
integration over here,
I didn't get a value
for the density, which
is g over lambda cubed,
the limiting value
of this f function,
which is zeta of 3/2.
I will call this n star
because this is strictly
less than the total
density that I have.
That was the problem.
If I could make up the total
density with z equals 1,
I would be satisfied.
I would be making
it here, but I'm not
making it up with the spectrum
that I have written over here.
But on the other hand, if
epsilon is incredibly small,
what I find is that the
occupation number of the k
equals to 0 state-- let's
write it n of k equals 0.
What is that?
It is 1 over z inverse, which
is the inverse of this quantity,
which is 1 plus epsilon,
which is approximately
e to the epsilon minus 1.
Actually, maybe what I should
do is to write it in the form e
to the beta mu minus 1 and
realize that this beta mu is
a quantity that is very small.
It is the same thing that I
was calling epsilon before.
And if it is very small, I can
make it to be 1 over beta mu.
So by making mu arbitrarily
close to the origin or epsilon
mu arbitrarily close to
1, I could in principle
pump a lot of particles
in the k equals 0 state,
and that does not
violate anything.
Bosons, you can put as many
particles as you like in the k
equals 0 state.
So essentially, what I can do
is I can make this, but you say,
well, isn't this already
covered by this curve
that you have over here?
Are you doing
something different?
Well, let's follow this line
of thought a little bit more.
How much do I have to put here?
This n is the total number of
particles divided by volume,
and so this is going to be
this quantity, n star, which
is gv over lambda cubed
divided by volume.
Let's write it in this fashion,
z over lambda cubed zeta of 3/2
and then whatever is left
over, and the leftover
I can write as n0.
So what we know is if
we take z equals 1,
this function will
tell me how many things
I have put in everything
except k equals 0
that I will
calculate separately.
That amount is here.
And I will put some
more in k equals 0,
and you can see
that the amount I
have to put there is going
to be n minus g over lambda
cubed zeta of 3/2.
Actually, I will have
to put a volume here.
Why is that?
The reason I have to put the
volume is because the volume
that I had here,
that ultimately I
divided the number of particles
by volume to get the density,
came from replacing the
sum with an integration.
So what I have envisioned now
is that there are all of these
points that correspond
to different k's.
I'll replace the sum
with a integration,
but then there was
one point, k equals 0,
that I am treating separately.
When I'm treating
that separately, it
means that is really is the
same as the total number
expectation value without having
to divide by the volume, which
comes from this
density of state,
and I have something like this.
Now, the problem is that you
can see that suddenly, you
have to pick a value
of mu that is inversely
proportional to the
volume of the system.
This is a problem in which
the thermodynamic limit
is taken in this strange sense.
You have all of these potential
values of the energy, epsilon
of k, that correspond to h bar
squared, k squared over 2m.
There is one that is at 0, and
then choosing k equals 2 to pi
over l, you will have one
other state, another state,
all of these states.
All of these states are
actually very finely spaced.
The difference between
the ground state
and the first excited state
is h bar squared over 2m,
2 pi over l squared.
So this distance over here is of
the order of 1 over l squared.
But I see that in
order to occupy
this with the
appropriate number,
I have to choose my chemical
potential to be as close as 1
over the volume.
So in the limit where I
take the size of the system
go to infinity, this
approaches this.
It never touches it, but the
distance that I have here
is much, much less
than the distance
that I have in the spacings
that I made this replacement.
So I can indeed treat
these separately.
I can give a particular
weight to this state
where the mu has come this
close to it as 1 over v,
treat all of the
other ones as part
of this replacement of the
summations with the integral.
You can also see that this
trick is going to be problematic
if I were to perform it in
two dimensions, because rather
than 1 over l to
the third power,
that is, the volume
in three dimensions,
I would have had
1 over l squared.
And indeed, that's
another reason
why two dimensions is special.
And as I said, in
two dimensions,
the curve actually does go
all the way to infinity.
You won't have this problem.
So this is essentially
what happens
with this Bose-Einstein
condensation,
that the occupation number of
the excited state for bosons
is such that you encounter
a singularity in three
dimensions beyond a particular
density or temperatures
lower than a certain amount
or highly degenerate case,
you have to separately treat
all the huge number of particles
that is proportional to the
volume that have now piled up
in the single state, k equals 0,
the ground state in this case,
but whatever the
ground state may
be for your appropriate
system, and all
the other particles go in the
corresponding excited states.
Now, as you go towards
zero temperature,
you can see that
this combination
is proportional to
temperature goes to zero.
So at 0 temperature,
essentially all of the particles
will need to be placed
in this k equals 0 state.
So if you like, a rough picture
is that the net density.
This is the density,
n, at high temperature
is entirely made up as being
part of the excited state.
Let's draw it this way.
When you hit Tc, you find that
the excited state can no longer
accommodate the entire density.
This is a coordination
that, as we said,
goes to zero at zero
temperature as T to the 3/2.
So there's a curve that
goes like T to the 3/2,
hits 1 at exactly Tc, which
is a function of the density
that you choose.
This is the fraction that
corresponds to the excited
states.
And on top of that, there
is a macroscopic fraction
that is occupying the
ground state, which
is the compliment to this curve.
Basically, it behaves
something like this.
One thing that I
should emphasize
is that what I see here makes it
look like at high temperatures,
there is no occupation
of k equals 0 state.
That is certainly not
correct because if you
look at this function
at any finite z
as a function of
epsilon, you can
see that the largest
value of this function
is still at epsilon equals 0.
It is much more
likely that there
is occupation of the ground
state than any other state,
except that the fraction
that is occupying here,
when I divide by the total
number, goes to zero.
It becomes macroscopic when
I'm below the BEC transition.
Now, the properties of what
is happening in this system
below Tc is actually very
simple because below Tc,
the chemical potential
in the macroscopic sense
is stuck at 1.
Essentially, what I'm saying
is that in this system,
the chemical
potential comes down.
It hits Tc of n,
and then it is 0.
Now of course, 0, as
we have discussed here,
if I put a magnifier here
and multiply by a factor of n
or a factor of
volume, then I see
that there is a distinction
between that and 0.
So it doesn't quite go
to 0, but the distance
is of the order of
1 over volume or 1
over the number of particles.
Effectively, from the
thermodynamic perspective,
it is 0.
But again, for the purposes
of thermodynamics, pressure,
everything comes
from the particles
that are moving around.
The particles in the ground
state are frozen out.
They don't do anything.
So the pressure is very simple.
Beta p is g over lambda
cubed, f 5/2, eta of z
equals 1, which is some number.
It is g over lambda
cubed, the zeta
function at 5/2, which again
has some value that you can read
of in tables, 1.34,
something like that.
So you can see that this
lambda cubed is inversely
proportional to t to
the 3/2, so pressure
is proportional to t to the 5/2.
If I were to plot the pressure
as a function of temperature,
what I find is that
at low temperatures,
the pressure is simply
given as t to the 5/2.
And you can see that this
pressure knows nothing
about the overall
density of the system
because this is a pure number.
It is only a function of
temperature, mass, et cetera.
There is no factor
of density here.
So what is happening?
Because we certainly
know that when
I am at very high temperatures,
ideal gas behavior
dictates that the
pressure should
be proportional to
temperature times density.
So if I have two different
gases where the density here
is greater than
the density here,
these will be the
form of the isotherms
that I have at
high temperatures.
So what happens is that you
will start with the ideal gas
behavior.
We saw that for
the case of bosons,
there is some kind of an
effective attraction that
reduces the pressure, so the
pressure starts to go down.
Eventually, it will join
this universal curve
at the value that
corresponds to Tc of n2.
Whereas if I see what's
happening with the lower
density, at high
temperatures, again, I
will have the linear behavior
of the ideal gas with a lower
slope because I have
a lower density.
As I go to lower temperatures,
quantum corrections
will reduce the pressure.
Eventually, I find
that this curve
will join my universal curve at
the point that would correspond
to Tc of n1, which in
this case would be lower.
But beyond that, it will
forget what the density was,
the pressure would be the
same for all of these curves.
And I have kind of indicated,
or tried to indicate,
that the curves join
here in a manner
that there is no
discontinuity in slope.
So an interesting
exercise to do is
to calculate derivatives
of this pressure
as a function of
temperature and see
whether they match coming
from the two sides.
And you will find that if
you do the algebra correctly,
there is a matching of the two.
Now, if I have the pressure
as a function of temperature,
then I also have the energy as a
function of temperature, right?
Because we know that
the energy is 3/2 PV.
So if I know P,
I can immediately
know what the energy is.
I know, therefore,
that in the condensate,
the energy is proportional
to T to the 5/2.
Take a derivative, I know
that the heat capacity
will be proportional
to T to the 3/2.
That T to the 3/2 is a
signature of this condensate
that we have.
Again, heat capacity will go to
0 as T goes to 0, as we expect.
And as opposed to the
case of the fermions,
where the vanishing of the heat
capacity was always linear,
the vanishing of the
heat capacity for bosons
will depend on dimensions, and
this vanishing as T to the 3/2
is in general T to
the d over 2, as can
be shown very easily by
following this algebra.
I wanted to do a
little bit of work
on calculating the heat
capacity because its shape is
interesting.
Let's write the formula a
little bit more accurately.
I have 3/2 v. Pressure is
kTg over lambda cubed, f
5/2 plus of z.
This formula is valid,
both at high temperatures
and at low temperatures.
At high temperatures,
z will be varying
as a function of temperature.
Let me also write the formula
for the number of particles.
The number of particles
is V times g over lambda
cubed f 3/2 plus of z.
Once more, I can get rid
of a number of things
by dividing these two.
So the energy per
particle is 3/2 kT, f 5/2
of z divided by f 3/2 of z.
Let's make sure I
didn't make any mistake.
Now, I want to calculate the
heat capacity, let's say,
per particle, which is d by
dT of the energy per particle.
Now, I have one factor out
here, which is easy to evaluate.
There's an explicit
temperature dependence here,
so I will get 3/2 kb.
I will have f 5/2 plus of z
divided by f 3/2 plus of z.
Something here
that I don't like.
Everything that I have written
here is clearly valid only
for T greater than Tc
because for T less than Tc,
I cannot write n
in this fashion.
So what I'm writing for you is
correct for T greater than Tc.
Point is that there is
also an implicit dependence
on temperature because z is
a function of temperature.
So what I can do is
I can do 3/2 kbT,
and this is a function of z, and
z is a function of temperature.
So what I have it is dz by
dT done at constant volume
or number of particles times
the derivative of this function
with respect to z.
Now, when I take the
derivative with respect to z,
I know that I
introduce a function
with one lower derivative
up to a factor of z.
So I divide by the
1 over z, and then
the derivative of the numerator
is f 3/2 plus divided by f 3/2
plus in the denominator
minus the derivative
of the denominator,
which is f 1/2 plus of z
times the numerator divided
by f 3/2 plus of z squared.
So what you would need
to evaluate in order
to get an expression
that is meaningful
and we can eliminate z's as much
as possible is what dz by dT
is.
Well, if this is our formula
for the number of particles
and the number of particles
or density is fixed,
then we take a derivative
with respect to temperature,
and I will get that dN
by dT, which is 0, is v.
And then we have to
take the temperature
derivative of this
combination, g over lambda
cubed, f 3/2 plus of z.
Now, lambda cubed scales
like 1 over t to the 3/2,
so when I take a
derivative of this,
I will get 3/2 T to the
1/2, which I can again
combine and write in
this fashion, 1 over T,
f 3/2 plus of z.
Or then I take the implicit
derivative that I have here,
so just like there, I will get
dz by dT at constant density
times 1 over z.
The derivative of f 3/2 will
give me f 1/2 plus of z.
Setting it to zero,
we can immediately
see that this combination,
T over z dz by dT
at constant density over
the number of particles
is minus 3/2, f 3/2 plus
divided by f 1/2 plus of z.
So what I need to do is to
substitute this over here.
And then when I want to
calculate the various limiting
behaviors as I start with the
high temperature and approach
Tc, all I need to know
is that z will go to 1.
f 1/2 of 1 is divergent, so
this factor will go to 0.
This factor will disappear,
and so then these things
will take nice, simple forms.
Once you do that-- we will do
this more correctly next time
around-- we'll
find that the heat
capacity of the
bosons in units of kb
as a function of temperature
has a discontinuity at Tc of n.
It approaches the
classical result,
which is 3/2 at
high temperatures.
At low temperatures, we said
it is simply proportional
to T to the 3/2, so I
have this kind of behavior
just a simple T
to the 3/2 curve.
And one can show
through arguments,
such as the one that
I showed you above,
that the heat
capacity is continuous
but its derivative is
discontinuous at Tc.
So the behavior overall of the
heat capacity of this Bose gas
is something like this.
So next time, we'll elucidate
this a little bit better
and go on and talk about
experimental realizations
of Bose-Einstein condensation.